what i want to talk about in this video
is shapes with four sides and the mathy
word for shapes with four sides is
quadrilateral
quadrilateral and anytime you see quad
as part of a word it's a good it's a
it's a good sign that you're dealing
with the number four somehow so a
quadrilateral is something that has four
sides so
that is a quadrilateral
this is a quadrilateral
this
is a quadrilateral they all have four
sides this
is a quadrilateral
even
this
is a let me make it look even
weirder even this
is a quadrilateral so what's not a
quadrilateral well a triangle would not
be quadratical it has three sides one
two three so let's cross that out a
pentagon that has five sides that would
not be a quadrilateral it has one two
three four five sides
a circle that has i guess you could say
no sides it's just one big curve it's a
circle that had that's not going to be a
quadrilateral if you had six sides seven
sides 100 sides none of that is going to
be a quadrilateral
so now let's think about the different
types of quadrilaterals or the different
categories of quadrilaterals
so one
is the parallelogram
so a parallelogram is a quadrilateral
and as we learn more math we'll learn
for we'll learn other ways of thinking
about this it's a quadrilateral where
opposite sides are parallel and parallel
is just another way of saying that
they're going in the same direction so
what do i mean by that
so something like this
something like this
would be a parallelogram why
because this side
is opposite to this side
and they're pointed in the same
direction they're going
they're going if i were to draw an arrow
if i were to draw an arrow here those
arrows are pointed
in the same way
so those two sides are pointed or are
parallel is the word we say
and
these two sides
these two sides right over here are
parallel
so this is a parallelogram so what are
other examples of parallelogram
well even your classic square
even your classic square
is a parallelogram and we'll talk more
about what makes a square special it's a
special type of parallelogram because
this side is going in the same direction
as that side
and
this side
and this side
whoops let me do that in yellow
and this side
is parallel to that side
so what's not a parallelogram
well something like
something like this
would not be a parallelogram you might
say wait i see two opposite sides are
parallel you might say look this
is parallel to this
but then you would see that this
is not parallel to this one way to think
about some things that are not parallel
is if the lines kept going they would
cross each other at some point while
these lines these lines right over here
they're never going to cross each other
so this one right over here is not a
parallelogram it has one set of opposite
sides being parallel but not the other
another example of something that is not
a parallelogram would be this one right
over here because none of the opposite
sides are parallel so parallelogram
opposite sides are parallel
so now let's talk about let's talk about
more types of four-sided shapes or
quadrilaterals
so the next one we'll talk about is
the rhombus
so the rhombus is a type of
parallelogram the opposite sides need to
be parallel but that's not that's by
itself that doesn't make it a rhombus
the opposite size need to be parallel
and all the sides have to be equal
so
for example
this
that i'm drawing
that is a parallelogram but it is not a
rhombus it's a parallelogram because
that side these opposite sides are
parallel
if you they kept going they would not
cross each other
and
these two opposite sides are parallel so
it's a parallelogram but it's not a
rhombus because the blue sides are
longer than the yellow sides so that is
not a rhombus a rhombus would have to
look like this
a rhombus would have to look like that
so opposite sides are parallel and all
the sides are the same length and now
you might say well maybe a square is a
rhombus and i want you to think about
that is a square a rhombus
are all the sides the same length and
are the opposite sides parallel
well we already said that the opposite
sides of a square are parallel a square
is a parallelogram and all the sides of
a square are the same length
so a square is a rhombus so one way to
think about
rhombuses or rhombi
is they're squares and you could kind of
view them as
kind of a
pushed over version of squares if a
square was moving really really really
fast in a cartoon that's what my brain
thinks of when i think of a rhombus
so now let's think of rectangle and you
might have heard the word rectangle in
the past but let's think a little bit
more about what makes a rectangle
so
a rectangle is going to be a
parallelogram but that by itself does
not make it a rectangle so for example
this right over here is a rectangle
why is it well it's definitely a
parallelogram
this side and that side are parallel
they'll never intersect
and
this side
and this side are parallel they're never
they're never going to intersect if you
kept going on and on and on or they're
never going to cross each other
but what makes it a rectangle it's
definitely a parallelogram but what
makes it
why do we use the word rectangle well
one way to
think about it is the way that they come
together at the corners
so in a rectangle
the things come into i guess you could
call them square corners and that's
called a right angle
that's called a right angle right over
there so this is what makes a rectangle
it's a parallelogram where all the
corners are right angles you could put a
little square there if you want to think
about it that way so for example
this right over here would not be a
rectangle why because you can't if you
put a square here notice that does not
you a square doesn't fit in the corners
the way that it fits right over here
that you have the square does not fit
over here
this is a parallelogram but not a
rectangle a rectangle is a parallelogram
that has square corners but what about
our square is a square a rectangle well
let's draw it out
well let's think about it a square
opposite sides are parallel we've
already said it's a parallelogram
and a square
has
the corners
are
square that's where when people say make
a square corner that's where it comes
from the corners are square they are
right angles so the square is a
rectangle so the square is a really
interesting quadrilateral because a
square
falls into all of these categories the
square a square is a square it's a
rhombus it's the type of rhombus where
the corners are right angles or you
could say where the corners are square
this one right over here is not a square
this one is square they're both
rhombuses or they're both rhomby a
square is also a rectangle
it's a parallelogram where the corners
are right angles where they are square a
square is definitely a parallelogram and
everything we've talked about is a
quadrilateral